j'accueille maintenant andré glucksmann
andré glucksmann bonsoir donc merci
d'être avec nous ce soir et philosophe
vous publié chez robert laffont un livre
qui s'appelle dostoïevski à manhattan
mais avant de parler du livre on va un
petit peu parlé de vous parce que je
crois que si on connaît pas votre vie on
comprend pas cet engagement qui est le
vôtre
vous êtes né en 1937 à boulogne
billancourt vos parents sont d'origine
juive votre mère de tchécoslovaquie
votre paire austro hongrois c'est sa
jeunesse à en autriche pour vos parents
et en allemagne
en fait vos parents étaient des agents
d'un réseau international qui
travaillait pour moscou et en 1936 il se
bat à hambourg contre le nazisme puis
ils ont passé de 30 à 37 en allemagne
nazie c'est à dire que marc dangereux
pendant la guerre de 40 donc votre père
disparaît sur un bateau d'indésirables
qui étaient torpillées par an ne sait
pas qui est votre mère qui parlait à
peine le français se retrouve en france
dans la zone non occupée avec trois
jeunes enfants
vous et vos deux soeurs elle aurait pu
partir en urss
pascal02 relations oui mais elle a
réfléchi et elle a choisi
j'ai eu et j'ai mis du temps à
comprendre ce que l'âme est choisie
parce que elle n'avait aucune illusion
sur les nazis vu qu'il l'est elle les
avait vus à l'oeuvre un et elle n'avait
pas d'illusions non plus sur staline et
finalement comment il a calculé c'est
assez compliqué mais elle s'est dit que
l'endroit où elles pouvaient lutter où
il y avait encore quelques amis c'était
peut-être préférable à un endroit où
elle était entre les mains de la police
alors c'est pour ça que je raconte ça
c'est lorsqu'elle était votre position
plus tard on va le voir en mettant à
égalité finalement le nazisme et le
communisme
ça vient de là pour ça que je raconte ça
c'est déjà votre mère à l'époque pendant
la guerre avait déjà fait ce
raisonnement
mais déjà compris la nature du nazisme
et la nature du communisme voilà alors
qu'elle avait deux formidables ma mère
c'est qu'elle n'avait pas fait d'études
etc elle résonnait avec un bon sens que
j'ai eu beaucoup de temps à récupérer
jouer ça y est alors en france au moins
elle pouvait se battre elle pouvait
lutter est ce que n'a pas été le cas
sans doute en urss et elle est rentrée
dans la résistance voila voila on
comprend maintenant comment vous êtes
construit aussi la résistance et alors
on comprend encore mieux comprendre
quand je vais citer cette anecdote un
jour vous êtes tous arrêtés par les
gendarmes français
vous êtes mis dans un camp de
regroupement pour les juifs en partance
pour l'allemagne et votre mère ne se
résignent pas du tout elle hurle elle
dit vous savez la vie aux gendarmes
français elle dit vous savez vous nous
envoyez vous savez bien vous nous
envoyez les routes sont complètement
apeuré parce qu'ils y avoir d'erreur des
représailles et bientôt vous aussi dit
elle aux gendarmes français
vous nous suivre et non ses fours
crématoires alors les gendarmes un peu
mauvaise conscience évidemment ils se
disent un peu raison effectivement nous
les français on entendra les envies dans
des camps et ils ont eu peur aussi c'est
très fort de la contamination série
sandy les autres détenus vont se
révolter aussi comme quoi il vaut mieux
parler donc pas mieux mieux parler que
de se taire mieux parler que de
s'écraser
voilà c'est pas une différence entre la
morale de réalisme finalement être mort
allait être réaliste quelquefois ça va
ensemble
alors là bas qu'est ce qu'ils font les
gens dans le francis débarrasse de vous
parce qu'effectivement votre mère est
très active un des bars de vous 4 c'est
à dire votre mère vous et vos deux
soeurs et finalement vous comprenez très
jeune en fait à travers cette expérience
à quel point le nazisme et le communisme
ont en commun la même chose c'est-à-dire
le totalitarisme et vous compreniez que
l'agitation ça paye alors à la
libération en votre mère s'occupe
d'enfants juifs dans les parents ont
disparu dans les camps et vous découvrez
le mal les effets du mal surtout en
voyant des tréteaux sur lesquels danse
des adolescents et visites qui faisait
les claquettes en reproduisant le bruit
des trains de la mort c'était assez
terrifiant
là j'ai compris que l'abandon c'était
quand même quelque chose d'absolument
terrible et quand je vois aujourd'hui
beaucoup de gens abandonner moi je pense
ou tchétchène par exemple abandonné par
l'humanité entière
je me replace dans cette situation je
suis allée clandestinement en
tchétchénie et au fond c'était un retour
dans mon passé
ouais alors malgré votre mère à 13 ans
vous inscrivez au pcf
vous y resterait jusqu'à 19 ans à
l'époque de budapest
quand l'armée soviétique du ca pour les
plus jeunes faire l'armée soviétique en
56 a envahi la hongrie je me fais
exclure peut exclure voulait pas être
cité ligne en fait exclure en 68 vous
êtes gauchiste version mao un an 75 ou
publier un livre important qui s'appelle
la cuisine y est là le mangeur d'hommes
qui fait scandale parce que la gauche
tout simplement ne supporte pas qu'on
lui parle du moulin mais maintenant
c'est mal vu alors ensuite l aventure
des nouveaux philosophes bernard-henri
lévy et puis des gens bien blige et au
delà de ça maintenant c'est plutôt
l'action humanitaire et les droits de
l'homme
oui votre combat ccc réveil matin si
vous voulez vous c'est bon mais il ya
beaucoup de gens qui dorment et il ya
beaucoup de gens qui meurent alors il ya
ceux qui dorment ya ceux qui meurent il
faut peut-être ça va essayer de faire un
contact alors dans le cadre de vos
actions humanitaires j'ai participé au
sauvetage des boat people en mer de
chine
à l'époque c'était les kouchner montand
signoret vous et participez avec bhl la
réconciliation pour la bonne cause
daron et sartre ce n'était pas évident
et depuis vous aimez les actions pour
l'algérie pour la tchétchénie
voilà vous avez pointé en fait au départ
dans la suite d'un art and vous avez
pointé finalement que le totalitarisme
était un dénominateur commun entre le
communisme et le nazisme est aujourd'hui
et ces deux sujets de votre livre à
l'aube de ce nouveau siècle
vous ajoutez finalement au communisme le
nazisme
un autre fléau qu'est l'islamisme et le
plus grand dénominateur commun de
de ces trois choses pour vous c'est
maintenant le nihilisme
oui ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de conflit de civilisation que ben
laden quand il fait sauter les twin
towers ce qui est dégoûtant et à mon
avis absolument dégoûtantes il n'y a pas
de d'explication de justification ce
sont des gens qui étaient là n'importe
qui 60 nations pas spécialement les
riches et on les écrase et on les
écrabouiller alors ça je trouve ça non
seulement écoeurant mais digne d'être
méditée alors je dis c'est pas eu un
clash de civilisation c'est pas une
guerre de religions ben laden ne
représente pas l'islam et il ne
représente pas les pauvres et pour moi
il y a d'une part des gens qui résistent
comme massoud comme les tchétchènes
comme les femmes en algérie alors parce
que je peux une parenthèse c'est bon
parce que en algérie vous êtes écouter
aussi tout le monde en parle demain je
sais est là j'ai des amis bon je salue
je sais qu'elle écoute
khalid a et malika parce que c'était des
femmes fantastiques qui pendant toute la
période noire où l'on égorgé les
collégiennes parce qu'elles ne portaient
pas le voile sont restés à alger ont
lutté à alger j'étais condamné à mort
par des fatwas qui circulait dans les
mosquées et elles m'ont beaucoup appris
justement sur la résistance au nihilisme
alors si vous voulez pour moi il ya ceux
qui résistent aux destructeurs et puis
il ya ceux qui extermine est alors
qu'ils soient musulmans qu'ils soient
hitlérien qu'ils soient communistes dans
la mesure vous extermine pour moi c'est
la même chose
vous dites que les américains espionnent
le monde entier toute la journée
et pourtant ils n'ont pas vu venir le 11
septembre
parce qu'en fait ils n'ont pas d'à
proches littéraire vous dit si vous
voulez savoir ce qui se passe dans la
tête de ben laden
il vaut mieux lire dostoïevski oui mais
les des américains on supposait qu'il y
avait des fous de dieu donc des
théologiens complètement abruti
d'une part et puis de l'autre des ploucs
des malheureux analphabètes mais ceux
qui ont organisé la chose c'était des
gens parfaitement éduqué des ingénieurs
des étudiants des fils d'abord car et
puis ben laden il est très très bien
éduqué et riche bientôt c'est vrai que
les américains n'ont pas vu que ces
nouveaux terroristes d'une certaine
façon c'était des gens à ces fanatiques
pour être des kamikazes mais assez
éduqués pour piloter des avions
oui qui a mis tout le monde comme ça
quand même voilà
et s'il avait lu un peu les russes de
ces ce qui serait perçu que c'était déjà
le problème du temps de la russie
tsariste
c'est l'histoire d'un groupuscule les
uns croient en dieu les autres n'y crois
pas mais ils ont un point commun c'est
que il estime que tout est permis qu'on
peut tout faire pour faire crouler le
monde qu après on verra
mais que pour l'instant on détruit on
démolit on tue pour pour rester avec les
auteurs russes vous dites on est sorti
d'une période commencée après la chute
du mur de berlin
et vous parlez de la cerisaie de
tchekhov c'est à dire une période
finalement où tout le monde pense que le
mal peut être le fourrier du bien et que
tout s'arrange toujours c'est cela tombe
bien c'est on a parlé de la fin de
l'histoire
julia main ce qu'on voulait dire c'était
que les grandes batailles étaient finis
les grands débats étaient finis les
grands périls était fini et qu'il n'y
avait plus que des petites histoires
dans les banlieues dans les banlieues du
monde c'est à dire en afrique cela veut
dire en asie et que on pouvait s'en
fiche
en fait et de quoi on s'est aperçu on
s'est aperçu que le lève ganis temps
c'était une petite histoire les familles
étaient bafoués c'était une petite
histoire les talibans détruisez tout ça
n'avait pas grande importance
et puis tout à coup on s'est aperçu que
ces petites choses qui n'ont pas de
grande importance comme par exemple
génocide au rwanda
ce n'est qu'à un million de morts bien
que toutes ces petites choses pouvaient
très bien agir
sur les grandes capitales que ce n'était
pas uniquement la banlieue que des
cavernes d'afghanistan jusqu'au tour des
twin towers de new york
il ya une conséquence est que si on
avait aidé les démocrates relatif mais
des vrais démocrates quand même par
rapport aux talibans comme massoud
si massoud avait été à kaboul eh bien
les tours en serait encore à new york
donc il ya une sorte de solidarité entre
tolérant entre démocrates qui est
absolument nécessaire très clair très
clair alors comment réagir au nid wismes
vous citer l'exemple du vol 93 de united
airlines c'est à dire qu'à un moment le
mec il dit on va tout faire pour que
l'avion tombe pas sur une ville dans
l'est couteau en plastique des
fourchettes en plastique mais on va se
battre
quoi écoutez c'est pas une question de
grands principes comme ça de grandes
théories
ils ont eu cinq minutes ils ont appris
par téléphone ce qui se passait sur les
trois autres avions
ils ont eu cinq minutes d'abord pour
comprendre ensuite pour avoir le courage
de réagir de prendre des justement les
couteaux en matière plastique et ils
savaient qu'ils allaient de toute façon
mourir donc ils ont agi pour sauver les
eaux ils ont agi parce que les uns et
mais leurs femmes mais qui ne voulait
pas que l'avion tombe sur n'importe qui
dans des enfants etc etc
et ça je trouve cela totalement
admirable c'est un principe de
résistance c'est un principe de
résistance qui est totalement universel
ça existe en occident ça exige chéri
musulmans ça existe partout les
tchétchènes il lutte depuis 300 ans
ils sont moins d'un million mais c'est
depuis toujours et ils luttent depuis
300 ans contre le grand frère russe
d'ailleurs plusieurs centaines de
millions de gens et ils tiennent et ils
font plus excusez moi mais il faudrait
quand même y réfléchir une tiennent et
ils se tiennent
parce que tout ce qu'ils subissent c'est
absolument horrible et anna politovskaïa
raconte qu'on torture mais qu'on torture
avec des injections de gazoline
l'armée russe torture les tchétchènes
avec des injections de gazoline j je me
suis gratter la tête jugent j'ai pas
compris il s'agit d'un gestion des
centres etc etc
et il ya de quoi devenir fou quand on
viole vos enfants devant les parents les
parents devant les enfants etc etc
et tout ça en public et tout ça en
collectif il ya de quoi devenir fou
quand on vend les cadavres aux familles
pour qu'ils les enterre ya de quoi
devenir fou et je crois que là les
tchétchènes ils sont en train de sauver
et les russes et nous mêmes parce que il
ne pousse pas la folie jusqu'au ben
laden is ils ne font pas sauter une
centrale nucléaire russe or ils sont
très courageux ils sont très astucieux
si vous voulez le faire
il y arriverait par peut-être pas la
première fois mais y arriverait donc ils
se retiennent et je crois qu'il faudrait
qu'on explique quand même à poutine que
c'est aussi son intérêt c'est pas une
question de morale simplement c'est son
intérêt et le nôtre d'arrêter ce genre
d'atrocité
merci en tous les cas je crois que c'est
important que vous veniez dire ce genre
de chose dans ce genre d'émission parce
que c'est regardé par beaucoup de gens
je sais voilà merci beaucoup
mais non c'est moi qui vous remercie